Last week, California governor
Gavin Newsom announced
that California's economy
is going to fully reopen by mid-June.
Isn't that cool?
Yeah.
This includes schools,
restaurants, churches, parks,
and of course office buildings.
Now, most people are happy
that things are gonna
be returning to normal.
They see it as a good thing.
But there's one company that is not happy.
Take a look.
[Narrator] For more than a year,
Zoom video software has
helped you stay connected
to your business, your
friends, and your family.
With the world coming out of the pandemic,
you might be tempted to
delete your Zoom application.
That would be a big mistake.
Hello, I'm Dave Zoom
and I know you're tired
of working from home,
but I guarantee you're going to get tired
of working in an office very quickly.
Or maybe you forgot what that was like.
Long commute times.
Crowded elevators.
Mean co-workers.
Unwelcome touches.
Microwaved fish in the break room.
Bathrooms where an intern
just went number two.
And whatever's happening here.
When you get tired of all that again,
Zoom will be right here waiting for you
with all new backgrounds
and new animal avatars.
Like this friendly owl.
Plus, we're adding new voice options.
Check it out, now I'm an owl
that sounds like Al Pacino.
I'm Owl Pacino.
I convey wisdom and intensity.
Woo! Woo-ah!
(laughs) Wow.
Zoom is run by a guy named Dave Zoom.
Yep.
[Conan] You knew that, huh?
I did not know that, I just found it out,
but it makes sense now.
Yeah.
I'm very impressed.